welcome to the science Asylum I Nick
lucid so Jimmy Starr wants me to do a
video on why time slows down at faster
speeds - comments huh
someone was determined first it's called
time dilation which is kind of a
misnomer the word dilate actually means
to become larger which is technically
the exact opposite of what time is doing
but at this point we've been using the
term for over a century so we're stuck
with it
second there are a bunch of traditional
ways to handle this but the last thing I
am is traditional you crazies know that
third we're going to need some context
let's see whoa whoa are you sure you
want to go in there it's scary sometimes
okay then let's say I'm standing on the
side of the road waiting for awkward M
then suddenly she zooms past at 80 miles
per hour time is going a little slower
for her because she's moving wait what
how come we never notice this well
because the difference is small like
femtosecond small one femtosecond is
point zero zero zero zero as 14001 for
some perspective take one second and
divide it into a thousand pieces one of
those pieces is a millisecond which is
already beyond human perception to get a
femtosecond you have to do that four
more times okay so normally it's really
small but not when things go that fast
we have to deal with it all the time in
particle accelerators we've measured the
difference using atomic clocks on the
space shuttle and no gps satellite would
work without accounting for it it's real
but what causes it to understand that we
need to look a little deeper no no not
in there yet there are a couple things
we need to make very clear about the
physics here
first of all space and time are just two
parts of a bigger idea
spacetime they are one and you're always
moving through it no matter what I might
be standing still and M might be moving
through space but time is passing for
both of us so these are the paths that
we each take through space time second
there are a lot of things that are
relative to your point of view but the
laws of physics are never based on those
ever they're based on the things that
aren't relative the things that are
always the same no matter what
your speed might be relative but the
speed of light is not we call them
space-time invariance and they're really
important space-time itself is another
one of those invariants space and time
might be independently relative but
together they are absolute now let's go
back to that car when M was sitting in
the driveway
she was only moving through time but
once she's moving through space she has
to give up some of her time to keep her
space-time the same if space goes up
then time has to go down it's as simple
as that
or is it centered on so what's the
fastest you've ever gone please share in
the comments and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy